all right it is an elevated setting for
a seasonally driven dining experience we
are talking about water grill las vegas
and joining us today to celebrate an
endless summer of wild salmon is
executive chef james defraga welcome
thank you for having me i was so excited
to hear about water grill you guys are
all about fresh and seasonal and salmon
is what's big right now huh most
definitely uh right now we're in the
middle of wild salmon season um and so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
prepare some california wild salmon this
is one of our preparations we're doing
currently with some heirloom carrots
carrot sauce and a seared california
troll salmon i love salmon and
everything is is fresh you can go ahead
and throw that on there so the key to
this dish is really making sure you have
a hot pan yeah and you want to get the a
nice crisp sear on the on the skin
i love salmon so finding new ways to
make it makes me so happy what's that
this is our vatavan curry spice uh-huh
we're gonna give it a little
seasoning on both sides
i see i always season the pink side i'm
glad i have a chef to tell me how to do
it right and we're gonna get a nice
little sear
on the skin
let it sizzle there for a little bit
and you you make the you're not only
famous for you know your salmon you've
got everything from lobsters to sea
urchins like the thing that makes water
grill unique is our live tanks as well
we offer things like australian spiny
lobsters live sea urchin
live king crab you can actually come
into the restaurant
choose your king crab you can take a
picture with it take it out of the tank
hold it up you know post for facebook
instagram all those kinds of things
i know he doesn't want to do it for the
gram right again we're the only place in
las vegas really that does something of
that nature um where you get to have
that experience and really choose your
your uh your dinner let's just say and
what you're going to put on the plate i
love it we have about a minute left so i
know we're going to get a nice little
circle we got us uh and we're going to
go ahead and with some tv magazines
now water grill is at the forum shops
inside caesar's palace so if you want to
check it out and i just love what you
have created here tell us a little bit
about the finished product so here we
have a seared
california troll salmon with heirloom
carrots and a vodavon carrot butter
sauce we're just going to finish with
the butter sauce the skin is nice and
crisp
we're going to finish with a little bit
of salt
that is just beautiful it smells so
fragrant what else did you put on
here we have some some pickled uh red
onions and a little bit of micro
cilantro and
some ginger as well with the roasted
heirloom carrots it looks fantastic if
you want to check out chef's just
creativity on fresh seafood again where
are you guys located we're in the forum
shops in caesars palace looks amazing
thank you so much